have you ever thought about how you hold
a isometric contraction let's say for
instance that you're holding a barbell
at a nice degree angle for as long as
you can you might be forgiven for
assuming that your muscle fibers are
somehow contracting halfway and then
just holding that position exerting a
kind of constant force at 50 percent of
your max in order to keep you locked at
that angle you'd be wrong however even
something as simple as this is far more
complex when it comes to the human body
and involves all sorts of different
processes understanding these is not
only very interesting but it could also
be useful for your training in the gym
and so without further ado let's take a
look at rate coding in muscle and fiber
recruitment as you probably already know
inside each muscle you have hundreds of
thousands of tiny fibers called muscle
fibers these are just thinner than human
hairs and they work essentially like
telescopic poles they have an inner and
outer filament made of actin and myosin
actin being the outer layer and this
closes over itself in order to shorten
and thereby shorten the length of the
muscle when they all work together it's
a little bit more complicated than that
there's really a chemical reaction using
enzymes but that's the basic concept of
how it works to trigger this contraction
you need a signal from your brain a
nerve impulse called an action potential
this is a small electrical signal that
travels through your nerves from your
brain down to the muscle across the
neuromuscular Junction and then causes
the fibers to contract now of course
you're not gonna have a separate signal
for every single muscle fiber because
that would just be too much so instead
you have a single nerve being
responsible for a whole bunch of muscle
fibers and to that a bunch of muscle
fibers connected to that one nerve that
is called a motor unit so you have a
bunch of different motor units inside
each muscle but these aren't just small
little sections of your muscles actually
all interweaved they can spread across
the entire muscle and they vary a lot in
terms of their size and the type of
muscle fiber they contain so you have
smaller ones which exert less force they
tend to contain mostly type 1 muscle
fiber that means that they're slow
twitch oxidative which means they don't
tire out quickly but aren't capable of
as much explosive force then you have to
be much larger motor units which tend to
contain Pradhan
type 2a and type 2b twitch fiber and
this is useful for powerful contractions
but they tire out very quickly what
makes all this a little bit more
complicated than you might assume is the
fact that motor units of binary they can
either fire or not fire they can't be in
the state of half fire once they receive
a certain amount of stimulation that
crosses a threshold an excitatory
threshold then they fire and there's no
set gradation there's no such thing as
contracting halfway there's no such
thing as contracting half of the muscle
fibers in that motor unit therefore
they're on or they're off and it only
lasts for about ten to 100 milliseconds
this action potential and this twitch
contraction and that's what makes it
confusing if you can only contract on or
off and if it only lasts for ten 200
milliseconds and how can you possibly
hold something at halfway point well
part of the answer is something called a
motor unit recruitment essentially when
you need to exert a certain amount of
force your body will recruit a certain
number of motor units only as many as
are needed to exert that particular
amount of force that you need and you'll
start with the smallest ones the
slow-twitch ones and then build up to
the bigger ones as more forces needed
this is called Henneman size principle
it basically means you always recruit
the smallest motor units first this
basically means that if you're lifting
up a small spoon you lose a tiny
percentage of your motor units mainly
containing just small numbers of muscle
fibers slow twitch muscle fibers but if
you're picking up a very heavy weight
you'll use all those plus a whole bunch
or more plus the really big fast twitch
motor units that contain lots of thick
muscle fiber and this is how you're able
to exert kind of smooth curve of force
how you're able to recruit more muscle
fibers as they're needed for heavier and
heavier weights at the low end when
you're in India a small amount of force
you're only increasing the amount of
power by very small amounts because
you're recruiting small additional motor
units but as it gets heavier these step
change increases so you're jumping up
larger amounts of force as you lift
heavier and heavier weights that's why
you're able to control something light
with far more precision than something
very heavy actually there's very small
motor units of firing all the time
randomly throughout the day to provide
you with muscle tone the small amount of
tension that exists in your muscle at
all times this keeps those muscles at
the optimal length the resting length
which is where you're at your strongest
it removes unnecessary slack so that you
can spring into a
more quickly at the same time it helps
you to maintain your posture and it
prevents muscular atrophy even when
you're sleeping there's a small amount
of tension in your muscle but during
those very explosive and heavy movements
we need to recruit those bigger motor
units and we need to recruit them at the
same time as each other and this ability
to recruit muscle fiber is one of the
key factors influencing our maximum
strength and it can be trained that's
why it's possible to increase strength
with certain types of training without
actually also increasing hypertrophy
because they work through different
pathways so that's how you can exert
varying levels of force but it doesn't
explain how you're able to hold a
contraction for longer those
contractions called twitch contractions
aren't just binary spikes themselves
though there's a small lag a small build
up before you desert the maximum force
and then there's a kind of cool off
period a relaxation phase it's only for
a short period of time they're in
maximum contraction to basically
accomplish this by sending that signal
incredibly quickly the action potential
fires so quickly that this charge rate
is so fast that there's no time for the
cool off period to happen so it's just a
continuous spiking and essentially that
is a continuous force this is called
rate coding the speed of those impulses
those discharge rates and this is how
the body the central nervous system
codifies intensity throughout the
nervous system so in the brain you have
your sensory neurons which receive
information about light and sound and
the more intense those stimuli the more
rapid to the right coding the faster the
action potentials so as you can see the
language of the nervous system is the
same whether you're talking about the
eye or whether you're talking about the
muscles this is what we call a Titanic
contraction when you have that
continuous force and the speeds of those
signals is something else that can be
trained and the faster it gets the more
force you're capable of generating so
when you hold something in place whether
it's a pen whether it's a weight that's
exactly what's going on you'll notice
that it's not actually locked in
position but rather it's shaking very
gently and that's because your body is
very rapidly pulsing the muscles in
order to hold it in place it's often
been assumed as well that synchronicity
in rape coding and in muscle fiber
recruitment would potentially result in
more force and strength the idea being
that if you could recruit all the muscle
fiber in the muscle at once or as much
as possible at once then you'd be able
to exert more force rather than
recruiting
slightly different times however it
turns out that asynchronous firing
asynchronous action potentials are
actually just as good and maybe even
superior when it comes to exerting force
especially over a long period of time
and this makes sense when you think
again about the very short duration of
those contractions asynchronous firing
would help to remove those troughs by
cancelling out the waveform essentially
then there are these safety mechanisms
that the body also puts in place to
prevent you injuring yourself by
recruiting too much muscle fiber at once
the idea being that if you recruited a
hundred percent of your large motor
units you'd probably end up tearing your
tenders especially because tendons
respond less quickly to training than do
the muscles therefore we have these
safety mechanisms in place to prevent us
from exerting a hundred percent of our
maximum force during an electric shock
all your muscle fibers fire at once and
this can actually propel you across the
room demonstrating just how powerful
your muscle actually is when you tap
into it all at once
adrenaline can help us to override this
and actually is a huge modulating factor
when it comes to our ability to recruit
muscle fiber and rate coding again this
is all stuff that I'd really like to
look at more in future so now you know
all this what effect does it possibly
have on your training what did you need
to know it buddy show that isometrics
and other forms of resistance training
are enough to increase your ability to
rapidly fire their signals thereby
getting more strength out of the muscle
that you already have on the other hand
if you use a very large concentric
contraction then you're gonna very
quickly recruit those larger motor units
if it's over 90 or 95 percent of your
one rep max then you're going to recruit
as many as possible you are never able
to recruit a hundred percent of your
motor units however you're going to
recruit as many as possible though and
that's going to much more quickly
exhaust you but that's what you want to
do if you want to train that mind-muscle
connection for those bigger motor units
and learn to exert more force from the
muscle they already have lengthening
exercises eccentric movements they're
going to train you in a slightly
different way you're going to again use
those larger motor units at the
beginning but then you're going to
intentionally be dropping out motor
units in order to exert the less and
less force the lengthening of the muscle
of course has unique effects for your
hypertrophy but it's also going to alter
the way you're controlling the muscle
this is also why overcoming isometrics
where you're pushing or pulling against
an immovable force are so useful here
you're recruiting as many as you
muscle fibers as possible because you're
trying to exert the maximum amount of
force that you can and you're holding
this for a sustained period of time
thereby strengthening that connection
further and allowing yourself to reach
fatigue on those muscles when you train
with submaximal amounts of weight maybe
you're doing 70 percent of your 1 rep
max for 8 reps that means you're not
going to recruit those larger motor
units therefore you're not going to
train yourself to be able to exert
maximum force this has other benefits of
course it leads to metabolic stress it
can help blood flow to your tendons it
builds strength and it builds size but
it doesn't train that connection to the
muscle unless you go to failure and you
go pass failure using something like a
drop set in which case you're able to
essentially do a pre workout for your
slow touch your muscle fiber you're
exhausting the Slater Trussell fibers so
they can no longer work and then you
have no option but to recruit the faster
twitch muscle fiber but as you can see
you need to consider all these different
factors when choosing the right type of
training the adaptations that you're
trying to achieve
then there's the effect that they have
on tendon hysteresis the conversion of
muscle fiber types the different ways in
which training will fatigue the nervous
system understanding all this allows you
to train
smarter and that's always a good thing
the take home then is to think about
this and to vary your training as much
as possible something as simple as
varying the speed of your contractions
adding ISO dynamics into your sets this
can dramatically alter the control you
have over your muscle likewise there's
much more to research here such as the
effect that electrical Maia stimulation
EMS could have on recruitment and rate
coding this means running an electric
current through the muscles artificially
to stimulate a contraction as you can
imagine this works entirely different to
an authentic endogenous contraction and
it will cause indiscriminate recruitment
of muscle fiber and predefined rate
coding some interesting research
suggests that EMS can actually increase
the number of ASA tile coline receptors
at the neuromuscular Junction thereby
perhaps enhancing the mind muscle
connection allowing you to engage more
in the future and finally let's just
take a moment to appreciate the amazing
complexity of the human body something
seemingly as simple as reaching for a
glass of water actually involves the
contraction of thousands of muscle
fibers across multiple muscle groups
your brain handles the necessary muscle
recruitment pattern to apply the correct
torque and force to multiple joints such
that your hand can move accurately
through space but then recruits only the
necessary motor units in the hand and
arm firing at a constant rate to allow
the necessary
to tannic contractions such that you're
able to grip the handle countless
systems are in place to reduce the
computational load necessary for such a
feat the myotatic response for instance
that allows muscle to shorten and
maintain its resting length low level
firing of slow twitch muscle fiber that
allows it to maintain tone in the size
principle that automatically recruits
only the necessary amount of force we
think that we control our skeletal
muscle in a conscious manner but in fact
we have no idea of what's going on here
under the surface so I hope you found
this video useful Oh interesting if you
did then please leave a like please
share around I really appreciate it
coming up next is a video on Leonardo da
Vinci what we can learn from him and his
life and then following that we'll be
going back to the Nightwing training for
part two of that series so if that
sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now